was going to have to come through for us
trump then told this mob to walk down to
the capitol
the signal was unmistakable these thugs
should stage a coup so donald trump can
hang on to power
the people's will be damned this beacon
of democracy
became the site of a vicious attack
rioters chanted hang my tents as a noose
and gallows were
built a stone's throw from the capitol
steps
capital police officers were beaten and
sprayed with pepper spray
attackers hunted down lawmakers to hold
them hostage or worse
staff barricaded doors people sent text
messages to their families
to tell them they loved them they
thought they were saying goodbye mr
speaker
this was not a protest this was an
insurrection
this was a well organized attack on our
country
that was incited by donald trump
domestic terrorists broke into the
united states capital that day
and it's a miracle more people didn't
die
as my colleagues and i were being
evacuated to safety i never
ever will forget what i saw when i
looked into the eyes of those attackers
right in the speaker's lobby there
i saw evil mr speaker our country came
under attack
not from a foreign nation but from what
but from within
these were not protesters these were not
patriots these were traders
these were domestic terrorists mr
speaker
and they were acting under the orders of
donald trump
now some of my colleagues on the other
side have suggested that we just move on
from this horror
but to gloss over it would be an
abdication of our duty
others on the republican side have
talked about unity but we can't have
unity without truth
and without accountability and i'm not
about to be lectured by people who just
voted to overturn the results
of a free and fair election america was
attacked
and we must respond even when the cause
of this violence resides
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue each of us
each of us took an oath last week it
wasn't to a party
and it wasn't to a person we vowed to
defend the constitution
the actions of donald trump have called
each of us
to fulfill that oath today i pray that
we rise to this responsibility
because every moment donald trump is in
the white house our nation
our freedom is in danger he must be held
to account
for the attack on our capital that he
organized and he incited
i solemnly urge my colleagues to support
this rule
and the underlying article the damage
this building sustained can be repaired
mr speaker
but if we don't hold donald trump
accountable the damage done to our
nation
could be irreversible i reserve the
balance of my time gentleman from
massachusetts reserve gentleman from
oklahoma is recognized thank you mr
speaker mr speaker before i
begin my formal remarks i want to ask
for god's blessing and protection on you
for my friend mr mcgovern for all who
come to this chamber today to speak and
to vote
for our wonderful staff that makes this
possible
and most especially for the men and
women of the capitol police and the
other affiliated law enforcement
agencies that are here to protect
everybody
and to make sure that this proceeding
can go forward
with that mr speaker i want to thank the
gentleman from massachusetts
my very good friend distinguished
chairman of the rules committee mr
mcgovern
for yielding me the customary 30 minutes
and i yield myself such time as i may
consume
thank you mr speaker well mr speaker
today is a sad day for all of us for me
personally
for the rules committee for the entire
house of representatives and most
certainly for the american people
for the second time in 13 months we're
meeting to discuss the impeachment of
the president of the united states
our meeting today does not arise in a
vacuum
and comes at what i hope and pray is the
end of a tumultuous
period for our country less than one
week ago
congress met to certify the results of
the 2020 presidential election
what started out as a piece as peaceful
protest turned into a riot
uh as an untold number of individuals
stormed the capitol building
six people died as a result of this mob
and it's
only by the grace of god and the brave
acts of the u.s capitol police
the washington d.c metropolitan police
the fbi the atf and other responding
agencies
that there was not more bloodshed
violent acts such as these have no place
in our republic these shocking and
sobering events
rest high on our minds today as well
they should
certainly january 6 2021 will live in my
memory
as the darkest day during my time of
service as a member of this house
after these grave events we as a nation
and as an institution have an
opportunity to come together
president trump has conceded the 2020
election
congress has certified the results of
the election and next wednesday
president-elect biden will be sworn in
as the president of the united states
congress and the nation can move forward
knowing that the political process was
completed is designed
as the constitutional framework that has
governed our republic since
1789 held firm but instead of moving
forward as a unifying force
the majority in the house is choosing to
divide us further
with only a week to go in in his term
the majority
is asking us to consider a resolution
impeaching president trump
and they do so knowing full will that
even if the house passes this resolution
the senate will not be able to begin
considering these charges until after
president trump turn
ends mr speaker i can think of no action
the house can take
it's more likely to further divide the
american people
than the action we are contemplating
today emotions are clearly running high
and political divisions have never been
more apparent in my lifetime
we desperately need to seek a path
forward healing for the american people
so it's unfortunate that a path to
support healing
is not the path the majority is chosen
today instead the house is moving
forward erratically with a truncated
process
that does not comport with the modern
practice
and it will give members no time to
contemplate the serious course of action
before us
in every modern impeachment inquiry an
investigation and committee action has
proceeded bringing an impeachment
resolution to the floor
in part this is to ensure that members
have the full facts
the opportunity to engage expert
witnesses and have a chance to be heard
it also provides due process to the
president of the united states
and again in every modern impeachment
inquiry the president has been given an
opportunity to be heard
in some form or another this is
necessary in order to ensure that the
american people have confidence
in the procedures the house is following
it's also necessary
not because of the president's uh
inappropriate
and reckless words are deserving of
defense but because
the presidency itself demands due
process in the impeachment proceedings
unfortunately the majority is chosen to
race to the floor
with a new article of impeachment
foregoing any investigation
any committee process or any chance for
members to fully contemplate this course
of action before
proceeding professor jonathan turley is
correct
when he called this a quote dangerous
snap impeachment
an impeachment that effectively would go
to a vote without the deliberation or
inquiries of the traditional hearing
professor turley also noted that quote
the damage
caused by the rioters this week was
enormous however it will pale in
comparison to the damage
from a new precedent of a snap
impeachment
unquote if the majority is seeking
consensus
this is hardly the way to create it the
majorities failing to provide the house
with an opportunity to review all the
facts
which are still coming to light to
discuss all the evidence
to listen to scholars to examine the
witnesses
and to consider precedents this is not
the type of robust process we have
followed for every modern impeachment
and the failure to do so does a great
disservice to this institution and to
this country
mr speaker i can think of nothing that
will cause further division more
than the path the majority is now taking
rather than looking ahead to a new
administration
the majority is again seeking to settle
scores against the old one
rather than seeking to heal america
they're seeking to divide us more deeply
and rather than following the
appropriate processes the house is used
in every modern impeachment
majorities rushing to the floor tripping
all over themselves in their rush to
impeach
the president the second time what's
worse
though the majority seems to believe
that this course of action is self
evident and that's simply not the case
i have to tell them it's not members
that
have reviewed the same conduct and have
come to dramatically different
conclusions
legal scholars like professor turley and
professor alan dershowitz
both of whom condemned the president's
statements believe that his statements
are not impeachable
i know other scholars have different
points of view
given this difference of opinion
shouldn't we have a better process than
this
shouldn't we have a chance to examine
witnesses discuss the matter with legal
scholars and consider this in committee
on a matter as grave and consequential
as impeachment
shouldn't we follow the same process we
have used in every modern impeachment
rather than rushing to the floor on
behalf of generations of americans to
come
we need to think more clearly about the
consequences of our actions today
the fact of the matter is mr speaker
there is no reason to rush forward like
this
other than the very obvious fact that
there are only seven days left
until the new president takes office but
what's worse
as professor dershowitz has pointed out
because of the senate's rules the case
cannot come to trial in the senate
until 1 p.m on january the 20th one
hour after president trump leaves office
this is an ill-advised
course in my opinion mr speaker even
senator joe manchin a democrat
agrees senator manchin is quoted this
week as having said quote
i think this is so will advise for joe
biden to be coming in
trying to heal the country trying to be
the president
of all the people when we're going to be
so divided in fighting again
let the judicial system do its job
unquote
so what then is the point of the rush to
impeach
we were coming off a horrific event that
resulted in six deaths
we have an opportunity to move forward
but we cannot if the majority insists on
bringing the country through the trauma
of another impeachment
it will carry forward into the next
president's term
ensuring that he will struggle to
organize his administration
what's worse it will continue to
generate the bitterness
so many of us have opposed why put us
through that
when we can't actually resolve this
before the end of the president's term
mr speaker i think my colleagues in the
majority need to think about this more
soberly
we need to recognize we are following a
flawed process
we need to recognize that people of good
will can differ
we need to recognize that while the
house may be done with this matter
after today's vote it will not be done
for the country
it will not be done for the senate and
it will not be done for the incoming and
biden administration
the house's action today will only
extend the division
longer than necessary finally mr speaker
i would note that there are other
remedies that can be pursued
the president is expected to face
litigation over his role
in last wednesday's events there will be
criminal
proceedings against the perpetrators and
i hope all of those who stormed the
capitol will be brought to justice
and some members have proposed an
alternative procedure
censoring the president which could
garner significant bipartisan support in
the house
i do not think impeachment is the wise
course mr speaker
i would urge my friends and the majority
to reconsider there's still time to
choose a different path
one that leads to reconciliation and
hope for a better and brighter days
with that i urge opposition to the rule
and i reserve the balance of my time
gentlemen from oklahoma reserve
gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized mr speaker i ask unanimous
unanimous consent to ensure to the
record the the powerful statement uh
by congresswoman liz cheney who is the
uh
chair of the house republican caucus uh
entitled um i will vote to impeach
president uh the president
without objection and i just want to be
clear about one thing um
uh if we vote to impeach the president
today and we send over the senate
there is uh there is nothing to prevent
the senate from taking it up immediately
uh if senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell uh
decides that he wants to proceed number
one number two we all want to talk about
unity
i can't think of anything that will
unify this country more if there was a
big bipartisan vote in favor of
impeachment
every second that this president remains
in office
is a danger to this country and to the
world we have no idea
what he is capable of doing whether he
will pardon these terrorists
whether he will go to war so i would
urge all my colleagues on both sides to
support
this this rule and the impeachment
resolution i yield one minute to the
gentlewoman from california
miss chu when he's recognized for one
minute
last week i hid in an office for hours
terrified to open the door because i did
not know if a rioter
was on the other side ready to attack
kidnap
or murder me but my experiences were
just the tip of the iceberg
the u.s capitol was targeted besieged
and ransacked on january 6
by murderous mob holding a noose for
vice president pence and targeting
speaker pelosi their rampage resulted in
destruction and five people
dead we were attacked by terrorists
but this time the terrorists were
radicalized right here in the united
states worse they were radicalized by
the president
who intentionally lied to his supporters
that the election was stolen and then
told them
when to come to d.c where to protest and
who to direct
their anger at the need to remove this
president
could not be more urgent he is too
dangerous to remain
in office donald trump must be held
accountable
he must be impeached gentlemen yields
gentleman from massachusetts reserves
gentleman from oklahoma is recognized
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i yield
myself such time as i may consume
gentleman's recognized thank you mr
speaker if we defeat the previous
question i'll offer an amendment to the
rule to immediately bring up a
resolution establishing a bipartisan
national commission on a domestic
terrorist attack
on the united states capital this
proposed bipartisan commission will be
tasked with examining and reporting upon
the terror attack on our
capital that occurred last wednesday the
commission will be bipartisan in nature
modeled after the 911 commission and
will fully empower
uh be empowered to undertake a full
investigation
and make recommendations to the
president and to congress i can think of
no more appropriate path for congress to
follow
than by ensuring a bipartisan commission
reviews all evidence and reports
back to us on this horrific event mr
speaker i asked unanimous consent to
insert the text of my amendment in the
record
along with extraneous material
immediately prior to the vote on the
previous question
with that i heard objection thank you mr
speaker with that i urge no vote
on the previous question i yield four
minutes to my good friend
mr davis of illinois a ranking
republican member on house
administration for
a further explanation of this amendment
the gentleman from illinois is
recognized for four minutes
thank you mr speaker i first want to
thank the u.s capitol police and the
sergeant-at-arms employees
who were here on the front lines
protecting this capital
last week during the unprecedented
attack
it is imperative that we focus on
ensuring a safe inauguration day
protecting members and staff during this
time of increased threats
and making sure that our capitol police
officers
have the support that they need we need
to ensure
that what we saw happen a week ago today
never happens again
yesterday i introduced along with
representatives catco and comer
a bill that would create a national
commission on the domestic terrorist
attack
upon the united states capital the
bipartisan commission would consist of
10 members
five republicans five democrats
appointed by the next president and
by house and senate leadership this
commission would be tasked with
investigating the domestic terrorist
attack that occurred
in this building just a week ago
and it will provide us recommendations
to prevent similar attacks
from happening in the future
what we saw last week scared all of us
who were here but also showed
adversaries
what it takes to take out a branch of
government
when this commission is done with this
investigation
it will submit a report to the president
and to congress detailing its findings
and recommendations
to ensure that no foreign or domestic
adversary could accomplish what was done
on january 6. we need to ensure that we
fully understand what took place last
week
and any and all issues that occurred
during
our response republicans and democrats
need to work
together we must unite to prevent any
attacks like this from happening
in the future and we must protect this
institution
not just for us for the american people
that's why we should defeat the previous
question so that we can establish
this bipartisan commission to equip us
with the information
that we need to support our capitol
police and the men and women
who work in these buildings and with
that i yield back
the gentleman yields the gentleman from
oklahoma reserves gentleman from
massachusetts is recognized mr speaker
i'm proud to yield one minute to the
distinguished general from
gentleman from maryland the majority
leader mr hoyer the gentleman from
maryland is recognized for one minute
i thank the chairman of the rules
committee for yielding
i congratulate him for his efforts
and that of the rules committee in
acting and acting
swiftly i appreciate the remarks of mr
cole for whom i have great respect
but i disagree with his
sense of the lack of urgency
in action i do agree with him of the
consequences
of our action
there are consequences to actions and
the actions of the president of the
united states
demand urgent clear
action by the congress of the united
states
the chairman of the committee introduced
the remarks and put them in the record
but i want to reference
the remarks of the chair of the
republican conference
which is the analog to the democratic
caucus
it is all the republicans elected to the
congress the united states
in the house of representatives and they
elected liz cheney the daughter of the
vice president
of the united states
former whip of this house dick cheney
with whom i served
in the 80s
representative cheney from wyoming
a conservative republican said this
the president of the united states
summoned the mob
assembled the mob and lit the flame
of this attack that is not some
irresponsible
new member of the congress the united
states
this is the daughter of the former
republican whip and former vice
president of the united states
of america she knows
of what she speaks and she said
this as well there has never
been a greater betrayal
by a president of the united states of
his office
and his oath of constitution to the
constitution
this is not as liz cheney says just
some action
she characterizes as the biggest
betrayal
of any president of the united states
in our history
mr john catkill not a back bench
republican who just got here and doesn't
know what's going on
mr john katko who is the ranking
republican on the homeland security
committee
says this to allow the president of the
united states
to incite this attack
without consequences is a direct
threat to the future of democracy this
is not some backbencher on your side of
the aisle
on their side of the aisle mr speaker
it reflects the sense of outrage
the sense of historic
dissimilarity from the actions of any
previous president
and then mr adam kinzinger member to the
ng commerce committee
a senior member from illinois so i have
a member from wyoming
a member from illinois and a member from
new york
there will be others on this vote who
will join them
and mr kendrick has said this if these
actions he hasn't had any hearings he
hasn't had any
he doesn't need any long drawn-out
consideration if these actions are not
worthy of impeachment
then what is an impeachable offense
there is no doubt in my mind that the
president of the united states
broke his oath and incited
this insurrection i tell my friend mr
speaker
a gentleman for whom i have great
respect he is my friend and i say that
honestly
not just as rhetoric as we say on this
floor because there's some
that i don't consider friends
whose values i do not share
that is not mr cole
we have a difference liz cheney
john catko adam kinster and other
republicans
whom i have talked to within the last 24
hours
believe this action is required now let
me say
i see the gentleman from ohio is on the
floor
he likes to say that we democrats were
elected and the first thing we wanted to
do was impeach this president
and he's shaking his head in agreement
because like the president of the united
states he denies the facts
trump-like fake news
december 6 2017.
mr who i'm going to refer to
offered a motion because he saw the
danger that confronted our country
and he filed a resolution of impeachment
and on december 6 2017 we had a vote on
that
and the majority of democrats voted no
actually they voted yes to table
so that we did not proceed
in 2017.
the gentleman from texas mr greene
thought however
the next year that there was still a
danger to our country
some of us shared that view
but we were not as confident that the
case could be made
or that the transactions that have
proceeded
would lead to conviction so on january
19th of 2018
we had a motion to table mr green's
resolution
and the majority of democrats voted
to table that resolution
what a rush to judgment and then
on july 17 2019
nine days before the call to ukraine to
get the ukrainian leader
to act on the political behalf of the
president united states
and withheld money to defend the
ukrainian people from russian
involvement
and offer that as a bribe
and on july 17th the majority of
democrats voted
to table that resolution so mr speaker
there was no rush
to judgment
and then that call to which i just
referred
was on july 26th nine days later
i call that the aha moment
yes i knew what i thought but that was
proof
and the gentleman uh some gentlemen have
lamented that we didn't know the
whistleblower because after all if we
knew the whistleblower
we can intimidate everybody else
from coming forward and this president
has done
everything he can to intimidate
whistleblowers
people who came forward and told the
truth and we had witness
after witness after witness who
confirmed what the whistleblower brought
to our attention
so the reason i rise today and i'm going
to speak on the resolution itself at
some later time
is to recognize the contributions that
al green of texas has made to getting us
to this place
and i just want to i'm not going to read
all the resolution but i want to read
some
excerpts from the resolution he is
introduced we won't be considering his
resolution
we'll be considering mr sicilini and
over 200
others who have signed on to the
resolution
mr greene had a resolution
when introduced resolve that donald
trump president of the united states has
impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors
and the following articles of
impeachment be exhibited
in the senate article
one says in his conduct with the
president of the
uh what excuse me in his conduct while
president united states
unmindful of the high duties of his high
office and dignity and proprieties
thereof
and of the harmony and courtesies
necessary for stability
which my friend spoke
the gentleman from oklahoma donald trump
john trump in violation of his
constitutional and faith
both faithfully to execute the office of
president
has harmed the society of the united
states
brought shame and dishonor to the office
of the president of the united states
discord among the people of the united
states
by weaponizing hate
for political gain
he went on to say on january 6 2021 in a
speech at the national mall
president donald trump weaponized the
hate and resultant that resulted in
violence the deaths of multiple people
an assault on democracy and an
insurrection
against the capital of the united states
of america by inciting a mob
who said that liz cheney said it
and al green said it
infected with white supremacy carrying
a rebel flag erecting a gallows
structure with the noose
wearing shirts and hateful messages such
as camp
auschwitz work brings freedom
and mega civil war january
6 2021 mega
civil war they had the hats on of the
army of maga
which i referred to as make america
grieve again
we grieved at fort sumter
we grew we grieved
on december 7 1941 and we grieved on 9
11.
and yes we grieved on december
excuse me january 6th
of this year he goes on to say
what the president told this mob that
liz cheney said
was recruited by the president of the
united states
and i quote this is the president
talking to this bob
all of us here today do not want to see
our election victory
stolen by a bold and radical
left democrats
like the secretary of state in georgia
and the governor of georgia
which is what they are doing and stolen
by the fake
news media inciting
riling up creating anger
with the fake news
and lies that the president of the
united states
said to these folks that is what they
have done
and what they are doing the president
continued we will never
give up
we will never concede
it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved and so what did they do
i'm cited by this president as liz
cheney said
as john catko said as adam kinziger said
and frankly what secretary chow
acted upon and what the secretary of
homeland security
acted upon
and what so many others in the
administration have acted upon
disgusted dismayed and disheartened
by what their president had done they
got out
they quit
the president further emboldened them
saying this is the green
resolution we're not considering it but
it is
green resolution the president further
emboldened them saying
you will never take back our country
with weakness
we had a display of non-weakness
criminal insurrection
like conduct
recruited by and deployed by
the president of the united states to
come to this capitol and
stop the the steel of course was
we assembled
accepting what all the courts that
considered it
said was a fair
an accurate election of joe biden and
kamala harris as president and vice
president states
after his national mall speech a mob of
his supporters proceeded to the capitol
complex we know that
until mr greene's resolution ends with
wherefore
the prevent to prevent national harm to
our society
donald john trump by such conduct
warrants
immediate impeachment trial
and removal from office and
disqualification to hold
and enjoy any office of honor trust or
profit under the united states
constitution and the 14th amendment
so in conclusion mr green is going to
speak after me
but in conclusion mr speaker let me tell
my friend mr cole
i've been here sometime he has as well
i've served with ronald reagan
with george h.w bush and george bush
i had respect for all of those
presidents
they cared about our country they
honored our constitution
and they executed the duties of their
office consistent with the constitution
and laws of our country
that is not true of this president
and therefore he ought to be removed
and we have that opportunity to do so
is there little time left yes
but it is never too late
to do the right thing i yield back the
balance of my
time gentlemen for maryland yields
gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized
here at this point i'd like to yield one
minute to the gentleman from texas my
good friend mr green
gentleman from texas is recognized for
one minute
thank you thank you mr speaker i
i had tears to weld in my eyes as i
heard mr hoyer
and i know that hearts are hurting
it's a very sad time in the history of
our country
no one is celebrating
no one wants to see this occur
i was at the rules committee by way of
zoom i was there for the entire hearing
those members on the other side this is
something that
they understand and they take seriously
regardless as to what's said i could
sense
that they're hurting too so i just want
to
thank everyone for all that has happened
and appreciation that's been shown
and i want to say that the healing that
we talk about that has to begin
may i have just 30 seconds
are you the gentleman 30 seconds
gentlemen has additional 30 thank you
the healing it also it has a start with
some of these people
who were there initially who helped to
lay this foundation
110 people i want to recognize
maxine waters congresswoman
a lot of them were threatened their
lives were disrupted
and if i may with unanimous consent i'd
just like to insert their names
in the record without objection i thank
you
and may god bless our country as we go
forward
gentlemen from texas yield gentlemen
from massachusetts reserve
chairman from oklahoma is recognized
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i yield
two minutes to my good friend
distinguished republican members our
leader of the budget committee
mr smith of missouri gentleman from
missouri is recognized for two minutes
thank you mr speaker if we defeat the
previous question
we will amend the rule to immediately
bring up the bill establishing a
bipartisan
national commission on the domestic
terror attack
of the united states capital this has
been
a devastating week for our nation
just last week we stood
right here in this very chamber while
violent mob
laid siege to the seat of american
democracy
it is vital we get the facts on what
went wrong
last week why the security apparatus
failed and how we can ensure it
never it never happens again
less than 50 feet from where we stand in
this room
a young lady lost her life through those
doors
through those doors i was in this
chamber when those gunshots rang
that is real stuff that should never
happen in the people's house
for the first time can the house
democrats
and the speaker of the house put the
people
before politics please
put the people before politics
at a time when our nation is more
divided
than ever before let's put
people before politics
president trump will be leaving in seven
days
let's try to heal this nation let's
listen
to the american people this is the
people's house let's
operate for the people this country is
hurting
the people are hurting our colleagues
are hurting
this is a reckless impeachment this will
only bring
up the hate and fire more than ever
before
have a conscience conscious put the
people
before possible from oklahoma
is recognized from oklahoma reserve
gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized
mr speaker let me remind all of my
colleagues
that what happened on wednesday would
not have happened if it weren't
for the occupant in the white house
and if we want to put the people first
we all ought to vote to impeach him and
remove him from office
as soon as possible but that i yield one
minute to the gentleman from california
ms brownlee gentlewoman from california
is recognized for one minute
mr speaker today is a defining moment
in our history congress was attacked by
a mob
directed by the president of the united
states it was a
horrible terrifying situation but we all
know
deep in our hearts that it could have
been much much
worse we simply cannot let it stand
we cannot let it stand for the very soul
of our democracy
we cannot let the president of the
united states
leave office without acting we are the
oldest constitutional republic in the
world and our capital is the sacred
symbol of our great democracy to my
colleagues across the aisle i appeal
to your sense of service and duty to our
nation and to the oath
we all swore to uphold before we are
democrats and republicans
we are americans let us come together to
fulfill our oath by voting for the
resolution before us
and by defending preserving and honoring
our democracy i yield back the
gentlewoman yields gentleman from
massachusetts reserves gentlemen from
oklahoma is recognized
thank you very much mr speaker mr
speaker i yield two minutes to one of
our new members distinguished gentlelady
from
south carolina miss mace and uh note
that this is our first speech on the
house floor the gentlewoman from south
carolina is recognized for
two minutes thank you mr speaker and
this is
not the reason why i wanted to give my
first speech on the
in our chambers in our hallowed halls
this is not what i wanted to do in my
first week
in office but after the violent events
of last week
watching and witnessing how
heartbreaking this was thank god i sent
my kids home on monday morning because i
was worried about the rhetoric
leading up to the events into the rally
on january 6th
the violence that could transpire not
only were our lives in danger but if my
kids were here their lives would have
been in danger too the two most precious
people in my life
mr speaker the president of the united
states the u.s house of representatives
has
every right to impeach the president of
the united states
but what we're doing today rushing this
impeachment in an
hour or two hour long debate on the
floor of this chamber
bypassing judiciary poses great
questions
about the constitutionality of this
process
i believe we need to hold the president
accountable i hold him accountable for
the events that transpired
for the attack on our capital last
wednesday i also believe that we need to
hold accountable
every single person even members of
congress if they contributed to the
violence
that transpired here but today i'm
asking my colleagues to remember the
words
of the legendary the great leader in
this country dr martin luther king
who once said the time is always right
to do what is right and if we're serious
about healing the divisions in this
country
republicans and democrats need to
acknowledge this is not the first day of
violence we've seen
we've seen violence across our country
for the last nine months
and we need to recognize number one that
our words have consequences
that there is violence on both sides of
the aisle we've contributed to it
we need to take responsibility for our
words and our actions we need to
acknowledge there is a problem take
responsibility for it
and stop being part of the problem and
start being part of the solution
god bless every member in the chamber
today and god bless the united states of
america i yield back
thank you gentlemen yields gentleman
from oklahoma reserve the gentleman from
massachusetts is recognized mr speaker
i'm happy to yield one minute to the
gentleman from vermont mr welsh
gentleman from vermont is recognized for
one minute mr speaker
our government is founded on the
principle all power
flows from the people donald trump
challenged this principle
in two ways deceit and violence
the deceit is repeated and baseless
assertion
of an electoral fraud the violence
the attack on the united states capital
on january six
the mob was assembled by donald trump
incited by donald trump
and in service of donald trump's effort
to overturn
through violence what he lost at the
voting booth
the violent mob breached the capitol
killed and
injured capitol police destroyed
property
threatened vice president members of
congress and staff
all to obstruct the peaceful transfer of
power
if we want unity we must have
accountability
so the question before this congress
will congress condone through
acquiescence
or condemn through impeachment donald
trump's violent
acts to overturn the election
gentlemen times expired gentleman from
massachusetts
reserves gentleman from oklahoma is
recognized thank you very much mr
speaker mr speaker i yield two minutes
to distinguish the
republican leader of the judiciary
committee mr jordan of ohio
the gentleman from ohio is recognized
for two minutes thank the gentleman for
yielding mr speaker
uh in his opening remarks the democrat
chair of the rules committee said that
republicans last week voted to overturn
the results of an election
guess who the first objector was on
january 6 2017.
first objector the democrat chair of the
rules committee
and guess which state he objected to
alabama the very first state called
alabama president trump i think won
alabama but like 80 points
actually want to buy but he want to buy
30 points they can object they can
object to alabama in 2017
but tell us we can't object to
pennsylvania in 2021
pennsylvania where the state supreme
court just unilaterally extended the
election to friday
pennsylvania where the secretary of
state unilaterally changed the rules
went around the legislature in
unconstitutional fashion pennsylvania
where county clerks
in some counties and you can imagine
which counties they were let people
fix their ballots against the law
fix cure their ballots their mail in
ballots directly by direct violation of
the law
and they tell us we tried to overturn
the election guess who the second
objector was in 2017
the individual managing the impeachment
for the democrats
americans are tired of the double
standard they are so tired of it
democrats object to more states in 2017
than republicans did last week
but somehow we're wrong democrats can
raise bail for riders and looters this
summer
but somehow when republicans condemn all
the violence
the violence this summer the violence
last week somehow we're wrong
and democrats can investigate the
president of the united states as mr
hoyer went through
try to impeach him investigating for
four years but will not look at an
election
that 80 million americans half the
electorate 80 million
republicans and democrats have their
doubts about
i i i said this last night i do not know
where all this goes
and this is frightening for the country
we should defeat this rule and we should
defeat the impeachment resolution
when it comes up gentlemen's times
expired gentleman from
oklahoma reserve gentleman from
massachusetts is recognized
mr speaker some of us objected
uh four years ago as a protest vote to
raise concerns about what all of our
intelligence agencies had stated clearly
that russia
interfered in our election but what the
gentleman fails to
acknowledge is that we all acknowledge
that donald trump was the president the
day after
the election hillary clinton conceded
the day after the election
uh and uh none of us pushed conspiracy
theories
like some of my friends on the other
side of the aisle have been doing and
this president
that somehow that the president wanted a
landslide
give me a break you know yesterday in
the rules committee i asked the
gentleman from ohio
uh if he would just say five simple
words and
he was talking about healing is the five
simple words that you could say that
would help heal this nation
or that the election was not stolen
that's it five simple words
he refused he said he never said the
election was stolen
well the evidence shows otherwise let me
quote from this dana milbank piece
entitled
five pesky little words keep stumping
jim jordan
and i uh and i and and mr speaker
the bottom line is this um
we this capital was stormed people died
because of the big lies that were being
told
by this president and by too many people
on the other side of the aisle
enough people should be outraged as to
what happened
it was unforgivable unconscionable
and coming up on this floor and talking
about what about ism
and trying to make these false
equivalencies
give me a break the president united
states instituted instigated
an attempted coup in this country people
died
everybody should be outraged whether
you're a democrat or republican
if this is not an impeachable offense i
don't know what the hell is
this president is not fit to remain in
office
with that i yield one minute to the
gentleman from oregon mr defazio
gentleman from oregon is recognized for
one minute
i thank the gentleman this was not a
one-off it was a long time coming
as a part of a plan to perpetuate trump
in office
trump's campaign strategy was
it the election the only we can lose is
it's
stolen if it's stolen it's fake it's
stolen
repeated by many of his fellow travelers
on that side
more than 150 times by trump over the
summer
then they litigated to disqualify voters
that didn't work
then they litigated to throw out ballots
well that didn't work
then they attempted to delay the count
and flip with state legislatures
well that didn't work last ditch the
president called down to georgia and
said can't you find me more votes
and then one last desperate plea stop
the january 6th certification and the
president talked about that
on september 26th he said
you know if it goes to congress there's
one vote per state
and we have an advantage so i think this
was
part of a plan to disrupt the electoral
college of the united states
giuliani trial by combat trump never
take back our country
from massachusetts
recognize the gentleman will suspend the
gentleman is no longer recognized
gentleman from oklahoma is recognized
thank you very much mr speaker
mr speaker i yield three minutes to uh
my good friend the gentleman from
pennsylvania mr russian thraller new
member of the rules
gentleman from pennsylvania is
recognized for three minutes thank you
mr chairman
i'm deeply troubled by last week's
attack in our capital
and i pray for the families of officer
siknik and officer liebengood
as i have been saying all summer long
violence and rioting
has no place in america and the
criminals responsible for last week's
rioting
must be brought to justice at a time
when our nation is still
healing we must seek out issues
to work on that unite us rather than
issues that further
divide us i was greatly encouraged to
see our country unite
in condemnation of last week's
lawlessness and the rioting
i am further encouraged that despite my
democratic colleagues claims to the
contrary president trump is committed to
a peaceful
and uninterrupted transfer of power
but that's not good enough for my
colleagues across the aisle with just
seven days left in president trump's
term they are fast tracking impeachment
proceedings
a move which will no doubt further
divide an already fractured nation
even house democrats last impeachment
effort which was rushed through in
record time
at the very least that had expert input
depositions
hearings and deliberation this latest
attempt
at impeachment ignores all precedent and
ignores
all due process it cannot be voted on in
the senate before
joe biden is sworn into office
i'm also very concerned by the charge
against the president
of quote unquote incitement of
insurrection
at his rally president trump urged
attendees to quote unquote
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard
there was no mention of violence let
alone calls to action
look i was i prosecuted terrorist navy i
was a defense attorney in the navy
jaguar i was a district judge
just pull up the criminal statute look
at the criminal code
president trump's words would not even
meet the definition
of incitement under criminal statutes
the measure before us today sets a
dangerous precedent
whereby political parties can justify
impeachment simply because they do not
agree with the president
i would therefore urge my colleagues
across the aisle to just take a step
back
let cooler head cooler heads prevail
and consider how the actions we're
taking here today
will alter the course of history we'll
lower an already low bar of impeachment
for all future presidencies thank you
and i yield back general yields
gentlemen from
oklahoma reserve gentleman from
massachusetts is recognized mr speaker
when my friends talk about the president
being committed to a peaceful transition
um
i i just point to what happened on
wednesday when his words
launched a violent attack against this
capital where five people lost their
lives and many more were
injured so give me a break mr speaker
you're one minute the gentleman from
texas miss jackson lee
i thank you contrary to my good friend's
words
the president of the united states is an
insurrectionist
he led an insurrection against the
united states of america
prior to the january 6 attack by violent
domestic terrorists
the president spoke to the crowd for one
hour
and these were his words these were his
words
which is that we cannot take the nation
back
we have to take the nation back with
strength
and you must go and do that
those were the paraphrase of his words
the president
provoked these domestic terrorists with
words
with actions and conduct that portray
and can have contempt and hostility to
the national value
of equal justice under the law telling
domestic terrorists
nearly all of them were white
supremacists
many of them who support him politically
who stormed the capital
to derail congress from completing its
constitutionally required duty
of counting and verifying the votes
gentlewoman's time has expired
gentleman from massachusetts reserves
the gentleman from oklahoma
is recognized thank you mr speaker mr
speaker i yield one minute to my very
good friend distinguished member of
georgia mr carter
chairman from georgia is recognized for
one minute thank you mr speaker mr
speaker i rise today in opposition to
this effort to move forward with
impeachment hearings
what happened on wednesday january 6 was
nothing short
of pure anarchy and those individuals
who broke the law should be held
accountable for their actions they
should be prosecuted to the highest
extent of the law
and they should be put in jail this was
one of the saddest days of my life last
wednesday mr chairman
our thoughts and our prayers are with
the police officers and other law
enforcement who carried out their duties
on that tragic day including officer
siknik
and liebengood right now our focus
should be on healing
healing our nation with so many upset
and dismayed that the actions of last
week is our responsibility
to chart a path forward to subdue the
growing animosity and find ways to heal
our country
unfortunately i don't believe this
resolution will achieve those goals
especially seven
days ahead of the inauguration this is
very serious and concerning effort
during such a tense and fragile time in
our country
i urge my colleagues to consider how
this will further entrench people during
such a tense time
i cannot support this the gentleman will
suspend all members are reminded to wear
face coverings while
on the floor all members and staff
should be wearing face coverings while
on the floor
gentlemen yields gentlemen from oklahoma
reserves gentlemen from massachusetts is
recognized mr speaker i yield one in one
half minutes to the gentleman from texas
mr doggett
gentleman from texas is recognized for
one and one half minutes
for years donald trump has honored thugs
worldwide
who suppress democracy for months with a
daily diet of lies
he has made clear his refusal to accept
any election in which he was not the
winner
after failing completely in his repeated
attempts
to intimidate both republican elected
election officials who are into
committing fraud
and republican appointed judges into
ignoring our constitution
he made a desperate attempt last week to
block the final election count
and prevent the peaceful transition of
power essential to democracy
trump basically attempted to overthrow
the government
to violently overthrow the first branch
of government
this congress like his deadly reaction
to the pandemic
he totally bungled the deadly attack
both his frenzied
riotous mob and his congressional
enablers
were defeated america we did stop the
steal
we stop donald trump from stealing our
democracy and imposing himself
as a tyrant today we not only demand
accountability for his gross misconduct
but more importantly we declare to the
next trump-like aspiring tyrant
not in america we love our democracy too
much
our capital is scarred but our democracy
survives
violating his sworn duty to protect and
defend our constitution by seeking to
violently overthrow the
gentleman's time has expired gentleman
from massachusetts this is reserved
teachable the gentleman
oklahoma is recognized thank you mr
speaker i advise the chair i have
additional speakers on the way but
they're having a difficult time so i
will reserve my time gentlemen from
oklahoma reserve gentleman from
massachusetts is recognized mr speaker i
yield one minute to the gentlewoman from
connecticut mr laurel
gentlemen a gentlewoman from connecticut
is recognized for one
minute
on november 3rd the american people
voted overwhelmingly for joe biden and
kamala harris
to serve as president and vice president
of the united states
the country was about to enter a new era
with great hope for change
and yet with a device a decisive mandate
and majority
the president used untruthful claims to
end the completion of a constitutional
process
of collecting the electoral votes making
joe biden president of the united states
not accepting the will of the american
people the president unleashed the most
horrific violence
that overwhelmed the security forces at
this capital
which was overrun for the first time
since 1812
putting the lives of so many at risk
indeed a day of infinity
this impeachment will be viewed as a
transcendent vote
where all will be judged
vote to impeach the president of the
united states
donald j trump and i yield back
gentlemen yields gentleman from
massachusetts reserves jonathan from
oklahoma is
mr speaker gentleman from oklahoma
reserve from massachusetts is recognized
um mr uh speaker i yield one minute to
the gentleman from florida miss caster
the gentlewoman from florida is
recognized for one minute
thank you mr speaker i rise today to
urge
the impeachment of donald trump because
the attack on the capital
and the congress was the single most
depraved betrayal of the u.s
constitution
ever committed by a president the
traitorous
incitement of an insurrection demands
not just
impeachment but removal of office from
office immediately
violence during the transfer of power
confederate flags
anti-semitic paraphernalia desecrated
this capital so accountability must come
swiftly we must act with the same
resoluteness
we showed in the early morning hours
after the insurrection
where we ensured the will of the voters
was effectuated
donald trump's defilement of this
capital will not stand it demands
impeachment now i yield back general
yields gentlemen from
massachusetts reserves gentleman from
oklahoma is recognized thank you very
much mr speaker mr speaker i yield
one minute to my very good friend the
distinguished gentleman from north
carolina mr bishop
gentleman from north carolina excuse me
two minutes for two minutes
thank you mr speaker i thank the
gentleman for yielding these articles
charge incitement once before
the house impeached the president of the
united states within a week of the
alleged defense that was president
andrew johnson
days after he removed secretary of war
edwin stanton in 1868.
over 50 years later the supreme court
declared
unconstitutional the 10-year office act
that president johnson had refused to
obey
in other words the house was not only
hasty it was
wrong punishing non-compliance with an
unconstitutional law
at least when that occurred the
constitutionality of the law in question
was unsettled
here however an angry house majority
races to impeachment in direct violation
of
settled constitutional law again the
articles before the house charge
incitement
to insurrection they do not specify
inciting language the law
is well settled quote
what is required to forfeit
constitutional protection is incitement
speech
that specifically advocates for
listeners to take unlawful action
the violence last wednesday was
abhorrent perpetrators should be
prosecuted those responsible for
security decisions held accountable
congress can disapprove revile condemn
even censure
but you cannot consistent with the rule
of law
punish that which the constitution's
first amendment declares protected
if you do it the violators of duty to
this constitution
however angry will be those who vote
for this article of impeachment it is
not mr green's article of impeachment
it is incitement and the constitution
is settled on that point thank you i
yield back
you gentlemen from oklahoma reserves
gentlemen from massachusetts is
recognized
uh mr speaker i'm proud to you one and a
half minutes to the gentleman from
minnesota miss
omar gentlewoman from minnesota is
recognized for one and a half minutes
thank you chairman mr speaker
let us not miss words about what
happened last week
it was a violent attempt to interrupt
our democratic
process it was a targeted blow at the
most essential
process that makes us a democracy it was
a direct
and specifically incited by the
president
of the united states for years
we have been asked to turn a blind eye
to the criminality corruption and
blatant disregard to the rule of law by
the tyrant
president we have in the white house we
as a nation can no longer look away
the president not only incited
an insurrection against our government
but has in word and deed
let a rebellion we could not simply move
past this or turn the page
for us to be able to survive as a
functioning democracy
there has to be accountability we must
impeach
and remove this president from the
office immediately
so that he could not be a threat
to our democracy i stand ready
to fulfill my oath of office
and i challenge my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle
to do the same i yield that gentleman
yields gentlemen from massachusetts
reserve gentleman from oklahoma is
recognized thank you mr speaker we
continue to reserve
gentlemen from oklahoma reserve
gentlemen from massachusetts is
recognized
uh mr speaker i'd like to ask unanimous
consent
to insert into the record new york times
article published january 9th entitled
our president wants us here the mob that
stormed the capital
um it's another example of why our
country cannot risk even one more day of
donald trump
without objection i now yield one minute
to the gentleman from california mr
correa
gentleman from california is recognized
for watching the gentleman for yielding
in
mr speaker last week congress was under
seized by a mob
motivated and directed by the president
of the united states
our vice president was a target of that
mob
members of congress both democrats and
republicans
were targets of this mob and i witnessed
for this first time in my life americans
fighting americans
all at the behest of our own president
of the united states
and as americans we can do better
and i will vote for impeachment today
for our nation for our children
and for our grandchildren and i'll be
voting for impeachment
so that america will once again be the
shining city upon the hill
who's beacon light guides freedom-loving
people
everywhere i urge my colleagues to join
me
and vote for impeachment with that i
yield the chairman yields general for
massachusetts reserves yemen from
oklahoma is recognized
thank you mr speaker i'll continue to
reserve general from oklahoma reserve
gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized may as the gentleman how many
more speakers he may have
uh if whenever the gentleman's prepared
to close we'll close
we were hopeful that one of our speakers
could arrive with difficult
circumstances or have just having a hard
time getting here i think we have
exhausted all of our speakers
uh so is my friend prepared to close
yes then i'll close me
gentleman from oklahoma is recognized
thank you very much mr speaker
uh mr speaker i yield myself the balance
of my time
speaker i want to uh thank you for
presiding over these
difficult proceedings today i want to
thank my good friend
the distinguished chairman of the rules
committee and i want to thank everybody
that came to the floor
had something to say at an important
moment uh
and i think the debate uh while spirited
reflected the civility and decency of
the institution that we're all
privileged to be part
of and i'm very proud to have been part
of it very proud of all the members in
the manner in which they participated
once again i thank the staff and and
thank those who kept us safe in the
process
particularly the capitol police mr
speaker in closing
i oppose this rule and i oppose the
majority's actions today
after the traumatic events of last week
the majority should be taking steps to
unite us
instead they are only dividing us
further they are rushing to judgment in
my opinion and bringing up impeachment
after failing to follow any meaningful
process whatsoever
no hearings have been held no witnesses
heard
no process or opportunity to respond was
provided to the president
no members had an opportunity to review
or amend this article before it came to
the floor
this is hardly the way the house should
undertake such a serious act
mr speaker there's still a way to unite
the country
let us look forward not backward let us
come together
not apart let us celebrate the peaceful
transition of power to a new president
rather than impeaching an old president
and let us affirm
and reaffirm with one united voice that
the house
does not rush the judgment on the most
consequential action we can take
we deserve better than that mr speaker
and the american people deserve better
than that
mr speaker i urge my colleagues uh
as they reflect on this minute and we
move into our next uh stage of debate
uh to remember that we're all privileged
to represent a great and a good people
who've gone through a horri a horrifying
and tragic time
uh and that we owe them the opportunity
to reflect and we owe them our best
efforts to bring together
i know people on this floor feel very
passionately about this subject with
different points of view
i honor each one of those points of view
and i honor the people that voice them
let's remember when we're through this
uh that we're one people
and we have one purpose that we're free
to the grace of god and millions of
brave americans over
centuries of time and we will remain
that way and we will move forward
together
once we settle this debate with that mr
speaker
i urge my colleagues to vote no on the
previous question
no on the rule no on the underlying
measure and i yield back the balance of
my time
generally he was back to balance his
time gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized thank you mr speaker and let
me thank my
friend the ranking member of the rules
committee mr cole for his friendship
and for the way he conduct conducts
himself
in this chamber i know he has great
respect for this institution
uh mr speaker it is impossible for me to
fully capture
the reverence that i have for the united
states capital you know i worked on
these grounds
starting back and host a college intern
working for senator george mcgovern back
in 1977.
no relation great last name um
but since that time i have done
everything for working as a staffer for
congressman joe moakley of massachusetts
to being elected to the united states
house of representatives myself
but that internship will always be a
high point of my life
coming here for the first time walking
these hallowed halls
and seeing the glory of american
democracy up close
the idea that someone would incite an
out of control mob
of homegrown fascists and domestic
terrorists
to desecrate the people's house fills me
with a deep
sadness for our country the contempt
that these people had for our democracy
and our freedom
fills me with horror and what donald
trump did
encouraging them fills me with rage
rage not just on behalf of all of those
serving here
but all those who work in these halls
and i'm talking about
the reporters the cafeteria workers the
custodians
the clerks the parliamentarians i go on
and on and on
and the staff the democratic staff the
republican staff the
non-partisan support staff who were
terrorized
some hiding under their desks and
barricading in their offices
i was in the speaker's chair the day
this unfolded and many of the people who
are sitting out there now
were present at that time what a
horrifying thing
for anybody to have to experience
now some of my republican friends have
been trying to lecture us about unity
here today
unity after they voted to overturn a
free and fair election in the united
states of america
but also preaching unity uh
and not acknowledging that for four
years
many of them gave oxygen to donald
trump's conspiracy theories
to the big lies they turned the other
way
in the face of racism and bigotry and
and how he embraced some of the most
intolerant voices
in this country they just let it go
you know i will remind everybody here
the words have consequences and ignoring
words that are wrong also have
consequences
you know what happened would never have
happened
if everybody stood up in unity
and called out the president when he was
not telling the american people the
truth
when he was pushing a big lie we will
never
have unity without truth and also
without accountability
this week in congress we saw the best of
us and and the worst of us
some of my colleagues have shown that
they will defend this president no
matter what he does
there's nothing that he could do that
would dissuade them
from all out support but some are
standing up
and doing the right thing under
tremendous pressure and i am proud of
that
and i honor them
you